where does the cocaine and the nicotine
come from
yeah is going to egypt
oh we got the drug testing guys here
i don't think they were doing any drug
testing back in those days no way
we're trying to figure out what is it
experimenting
we really go deep here well it's
interesting about
the pyramids and the sphinx
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot boxing i'm evan britton and i'm
mike tyson
we got a great guest today mike big time
we're getting great guests the better
the better they can
we just get the best people in here man
we've got jeff novitskiy aka
the golden snitch oh no that's not a
golden smith that's
he's a discoverer of people that's doing
devolution worship and wicked things
people that are hurting people
physically i like that interpretation
dude
well jeff it's great to have you man
yeah thanks for having me guys man i
appreciate it
it's an honor it's honored to be here
with you this is um explain your
situation to the people who
are you jeff yeah so my current role i'm
the vice president of athlete health and
performance with ufc
my uh my main role with the ufc is i
oversee
what i believe is the world's best
anti-doping program in professional
sports
and i based that not off of opinion but
off of experience before i came to the
ufc
i was a federal agent in the united
states for about 23 years
and about halfway through my career ran
into an investigation called balco
laboratories
and it turned out to be one of the
highest profile performance enhancing
drug distribution cases really
in the world um and so thereafter i
kind of became that point person where
anybody not only in the u.s but really
worldwide anytime you saw
somebody investigating something that
came across steroids or growth hormones
or things in sports
inevitably they'd call me up and just
ask for advice on how i worked my case
so
really the last 12 13 years of my career
i mean i talked to agents in
the united states and spain and france
and australia
anytime anybody came across something
they'd usually pick up the phone to call
me to get my advice on
what they were seeing and potentially
how to work it so
former athlete myself i mean i was just
fascinated by it fascinated by what
these drugs can do
fascinated by the temptations that these
athletes felt to do it and there's a lot
of temptation
and listen um i don't even blame the
athletes
you know i can't blame them you know
what this is going to give it's going to
give you your dreams
this is going to give you your dreams
i'll put you so close to your dreams
you're going to get them you're going to
touch them it's just um
it's hard to even say no this is what
and this is the truth um
if an athlete very few athletes that
could say
i just want to see if i'm better than
him it's clean i just want to see him
i'm better than man for man can i beat
him
you know we want to believe that but we
have but
i can make sure i'm better if i take
this though i guarantee me to be better
you know it's tough for us because some
of us don't like to don't like to touch
who we really are we're really
really winners or losers sometimes we
doubt who we are even though we are that
great energy we doubt it sometimes
so um it could be it could be like um
it's easier to say this take this this
would be easier
yeah and make me better yeah but then
you find people that you say i won't
take it i think i'm the best in the
world
no one could beat me i'm going to fight
him without it
so jeff you really focused have or at
least
you know much of your career has been
focused on performance-enhancing drugs
correct um and yeah i mean i i
absolutely 100 agree with mike and a lot
of people were surprised with that you
know
people ask me like oh you must all these
athletes must think that
you know you hate them they're wrong i'm
exactly in mike's camp i completely
got why they made that decision and you
know if i'm in my early 20s
and i'm a professional baseball player
in the late 90s
and i see what's going on in baseball
and i'm coming up from the minor leagues
into that major league clubhouse and
it's my dream to play in the major
leagues and i realized very quickly that
unless i get on this program
my time here is limited and and the
reward for having a great season
millions of dollars you come from you
know that type of background it
completely changes
your life your family's life man who is
not going to make that you know take it
would be the rare person
that would not choose and it's abundance
of money and everything out here there's
enough money for everybody to have
over and over again and still we don't
have it you think i won't take that
chance
yeah man i remember playing in the nfl
you know making it to the league
and then you know performance enhancing
drugs in the nfl
are i know i didn't see many guys taking
them i think the policy in the league
is strict enough at least to catch
the common ones there might be some guys
doing hgh or some undetectable stuff
maybe you can talk a little bit
speak to that about you know what is
detectable and what isn't
um but you know for me it was like
some of these guys i looked up to my
whole life as a young player
doing everything clean coming into the
league you know now guys are
i'm being taken by a veteran into the
training room to get a shot at toradol
before the game yeah because that's just
the way it's done
come on come get this shot you'll feel
like a million bucks a hundred percent
you'll feel like you can run through a
wall
well you know one thing i notice it's
very evident with the nfl
is that you know and i see this and i've
talked to athletes there's constantly a
risk
reward calculation going on in their
heads the rewards are obvious these
there's no doubt about it anybody who
says like ah steroids growth hormone
doesn't really work
is full of [ __ ] they don't know what
they're talking about it works
yeah as good as you can imagine it
working so
you know play that off what the penalty
is in the nfl for a first time now in
the nfl it's a four game suspension so
you're missing a quarter of the year
so the first suspension four games
what what is it after that i mean i
should know but i
maybe doubled maybe eight or maybe a
season but yeah eventually they're gonna
make um a chemical that's gonna um
camouflaged it yes i'm talking about
that so mike you're right i mean there
are these chemists out there and and
incredible in the background they are
they make stuff in their garage
these guys in the backyard doing
incredible genius [ __ ]
unless you know in anti-doping what
you're looking for
you can't find it there for whatever
drug is out there there has to be a
specific test
that recognizes that drug so what these
chemists are doing is
taking a steroid a known steroid and
adding an extra
atom molecule whatever on it and it
still retains the benefits of the
steroid but it won't show up on a
traditional test unless the science
finds out about it and creates a test
for it
so it's a constant cat and mouse game
interesting
i was telling um a couple of years ago i
was telling finally hey man i'm
rolling my dick my dick is not getting
harder so yeah you should
he said come over mike i got something
for you so i'm gonna shoot you in the
head of your dick it's never gonna go
down i'm like
oh [ __ ] i wanted to do it so bad i
wanted to do so bad you're so scared
he's not like
it's gonna last forever mike it'll never
go down
i said [ __ ] i just wanted something did
you do it no i just wanted some viagra
son or something yeah he's a [ __ ]
don't please mike trust me i said
[ __ ] my tip of my deck of stickers
need a long needle [ __ ] no
that's another kind of performance i
think i gotta have them hold my dick in
style
[ __ ] no [ __ ] i couldn't do that
oh terrible dude well we were talking
earlier before we came in here about the
wizonator
oh so yes now and and really i mean it's
i say this all the time how much respect
i have for our athletes because not only
are they having to
take a pee in front of somebody but
somebody who's up close
and personal on their knees watching
that pee come right out of them
and that's because of this device that
you know in the past it was a wizonator
which was a prosthetic
yeah it was awesome yeah with you put
clean urine yeah i put no i put my
baby's urine in it oh
my god i'm i'm just hoping i'm just
hoping that one day i use my wife my
wife said
baby you better not hope that he comes
back pregnant or something
and i said nothing we ain't going to use
you know we're going to use the kids
because i got scared that the piss might
come back pregnant
you're pregnant yeah i think that's
happened before in the world
i think a male 1 urine sample and i came
back said sir uh you're pregnant yes
that's what i was afraid of i guess i
didn't hear that happening since i was
afraid of that
yes well did you have the right color
whizzinator because it was that it felt
like
hell yeah one
what was that i heard that stuff but
this guy this guy was so
[ __ ] macho he was scared i wept it
out he was like hey man take the [ __ ]
cup you know his macho guy
he don't look at me and [ __ ]
yeah you gotta play those dudes yeah
it's the worst job
it is man so our testers not only are
they closely observing you know our
athletes in a very intimate way
they're waking our athletes up five six
in the morning because as we talked
about earlier in a good
solid anti-doping program you could
never know when the tester's coming
yeah it could be early at night it could
be late or early in the morning that
comes from the prison system
they learned that from the prison system
because that's what they do in the
prison they never let you know they come
here sleeping
dumb can i get a drug test come on drug
test you piss right here
really yeah right here wake up get a
piss right here
could you could you imagine having to be
that guy or girl i mean
we have some of the toughest individuals
on the planet earth in some of the
baddest areas on the planet earth they
live in
so knocking on somebody's door in a bad
neighborhood at five nothing
there's no ever any good news when
someone's knocking on your door at five
or six nights that's not a good thing
and some of them probably are not gonna
do it from on the side and not no doubt
in training camp they'd come pound on
your door at about 4
30 in the morning check out that we had
an instance two weeks ago
so one of our fighters knock on the door
i think it's 5 30 6 a.m
opens it up and this woman says hey i'm
here to take your blood so this guy's
like okay this is probably a ufc test
come on in so he starts giving the blood
and starts noticing man this isn't
usually how this happens
she's taking a [ __ ] load of blood out of
me so he goes
is this is more than uh than you
normally take isn't it and she goes
oh john don't worry and guess john come
on because my name is dan
oh no get something she got the wrong
house i wouldn't believe it if you were
oh she had the wrong house it was the
same number
but the next street over what are the
[ __ ] odds that someone at
six in the morning is there to collect
blood and the person's used to it oh
yeah i mean just that would never happen
in a million years that's a nightmare
first of all i'm curious what the ufc's
policy is
because you said that you watched uh
henry's episode cejudo i did
uh you know we love cody garbrandt here
yeah what happens to cody after all that
stuff now this guy beats me
he's using [ __ ] yeah he beats me now we
find that he's dirty what happens to me
how do i get that how do i get a fight
with him that he's clean how did he get
that belt removed how do i get my title
back because i wasn't beat
fairly yeah so i mean tj's belt was
removed he you know gave it up but what
happens for me
yeah for t i mean that's a question for
for cody that's a question for dana but
i mean i would assume
based on what happened right back in the
picture again yeah did you become number
one to contender
yeah again that that's in dana's world
not necessarily mine but that'd be my
guess
absolutely right yeah so talk about
epo yup that's that is
um similar to blood that is blood doping
that's like oxygen
won't catch cramps and [ __ ] no so you
want more red blood cells in your body
because that carries more oxygen to your
muscles and allows you to work harder
and longer and allows you to recover
quicker um
is that dangerous to you does it hurt if
you have
yeah the danger with blood doping and
epo is the more red blood cells you have
the thicker your blood becomes
and if you have any type of blockage in
your body you know in a vein or whatever
it can
that those red blood cells can block it
up quick give you a great example of
this so in professional cycling
epo kind of came on the scene in the
late 80s
and what these cyclists were realizing
was holy [ __ ] like i'll pinch you know
i'll prick myself with a needle
and the blood barely even comes out
because it's so thick
so they would set alarms for three in
the morning
have a tall glass of water next to the
red wake up
chug the water and get on the floor and
do you know 30 or 40 push-ups in order
to keep their blood circulating for fear
of
my blood's becoming so thick it's going
to clog up
so super super dangerous if you're not
doing it right and get that red blood
cell count up
too high there were some cyclists in the
late 80s that were dying i mean some of
the best in shape athletes on the planet
dying in their late 20s and early 30s of
strokes and heart attacks
listen that was so ironic when you say
something like that when you're just
you know when you see an average person
like a young athlete or something a
young person then you just thinking
you're not even thinking about the
afterlife you're not that conscious yet
and this think about it what i give up
um
say i'm 20 i'm going to die at 50. 50
[ __ ] old anything i got 30 [ __ ]
years to do it
so i would rather die at 30 and live the
life of a god
yeah yep there's a there's a famous poll
they take
every four years at the olympics and
they ask olympic athletes where i came
from
glory yeah i won't go over i don't want
some money let's give me some glory
other than just being [ __ ]
abnormal just a normal [ __ ] in
the hood just give me girl you don't
have to give me money just give me
somebody know my name and pat me on my
back
yeah yeah
yeah they they pulled the olympic
athletes every four years saying if
there was a pill that allowed you to
make win a gold medal
but would take 10 to 20 years off your
life would you choose to do that
and every year majority 90 like hell
yeah
we don't even have kids yet yeah we
don't even know the concept of loving
our kids more than we love ourselves yet
yeah when we get that concept by concept
of life change
we want our life we want to spend time
with this child
did you ever take any performance
enhancers mike i take [ __ ] um
i did marijuana yeah well talk about
that jeff because you're
you're actually an advocate for cbd and
you guys i think have one of the most
forward thinking policies on it as far
as i can tell
yeah so just it was like last year the
year before cbd
became allowed to take at all times so
there's our fighters can take it you
know without restriction
at any time marijuana or thc
only tested for in the in competition
period which would be weigh-in day or
fight day
you said something earlier that i
thought was interesting
uh on the thc side of things
which is there is a threshold it's 150
nanograms per milliliter now that may
not mean much
to the non-scientists but you know um
it's probably what we recommend to our
fighters
is if you stop using it you know the
problem is everybody metabolizes
differently so it's
i'd hate to tell you know mike's one of
our fighters says hey jeff when should i
stop
you know using i tell him a week he just
happens to metabolize differently and
he pops then it's on me so i'm always
out of an abundance of caution giving
them a little
longer window but the reality is you
know a week or two likely would
you know put you under that limit i'd
love to see something
you know along the lines of like alcohol
i mean
you could never you're not allowed to be
drunk to go in and box or fight mma but
they're not testing for alcohol
listen um you've got inspectors in the
locker room fighters that didn't they've
been on they can't fight without
drinking they got to be drunk to fight
they can't they don't got the nerve
they don't have enough they got to be
drunk world champion they got to be
can't do this [ __ ] [ __ ] without my
[ __ ] alcohol my right-handed
card
yeah i've seen guys take shots out
frankie ramsey
world champion beat chad the first guy
to beat chapter record like 89 and
oh the first guy would be the alcoholic
so while we have a threshold and this is
an industry store i found this out
yesterday and
a connection here to mike so while we
have this threshold so you can have some
in your system it just can't be over an
amount
some states where we go the athletic
commissions have rules
where you can have none and you know
what's whose state still has a no
tolerance rule
where did you test positive for
marijuana michigan
really we still go to michigan and they
don't allow
one ounce or iota thc or marijuana
which is [ __ ] ridiculous you could
smoke a joint a month before the fight
and still have some in yourself they do
that because they want to collect the
money it's all financial
yeah i don't know maybe a little that it
may just them trying to you know impose
their moral issues on
they're not ignorant people just there's
no place in
you know an anti-doping program in an
anti-doping program you're trying to
create a fair
and level playing field what difference
does it make if somebody
you know smoke something a month out
what difference in my opinion does it
make
if someone's nervous and can't sleep the
night before a competition
yeah fellaini uses some marijuana to
just relax themselves
i couldn't get the guy got me nervous
he's really big and [ __ ] and got me
and he got me nervous that's not giving
you an advantage the next night when
you're going to fight it's just
it should be good if anything you know
um so are so fighters are test are they
tested the day
of the fight so they can be tested the
day of the fight the night of the fight
the day but they can be tested
to any time it's okay they normally take
test you like a week before you fight
they do they do that i'm the aids test
and all that stuff normally a week
before the fight
yeah that's for the commission for
medical purposes to make sure hepatitis
you know aids those types of things for
our testing the anti-doping testing
are the ufc fighters subject to the test
365 days a year
24 hours a day they never always be
afraid to take the aids test too you do
that before every test you
or before every fight you do an aids
test hell
yeah and listen no listen so next thing
right i'm at a fight
and so tommy the duke morrison's about
to fight he's the main event
and then a doctor who's a friend of mine
come in and say nah he's not fighting
tonight i don't think he's ever going to
fight again
and i'm saying like wow he must really
be hurt or something right but he said
no
mike you'll find out he didn't want to
tell me right there tonight we're going
to find out
but he already knew and he found the guy
had um hiv
and they canceled this fight the main
event wow and i'm like
[ __ ] if he got i know he don't get more
[ __ ] than me and don't do [ __ ] that i
do i'm like
[ __ ] i'm dead
[ __ ] oh
[ __ ] dude that's crazy mike [ __ ] man
we have fun here this is awesome we have
fun i love it
um well you said something interesting
earlier as well about
how thc the concern is that maybe having
thc
in your system during the fight could
help you endure more
damage that's at least the theory i mean
i don't know
whether there's weight to that because i
mean i've never i'm not a fighter so i
wouldn't
i wouldn't know yeah yeah what do you
think
listen i know this right
this is what i know i know if three of
us
all had altercations with one another
and we put some liquor in this room
we'll kill each other
you know and i know if we all had
altercation and we started smoking some
weed we all start taking selfies with
one another and [ __ ]
right say man [ __ ] that [ __ ] i love you
man that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
you know i used to i didn't know that
because i've been in that situation i
saw what the effects of both of them do
and that's all i know from that
perspective but how would it relate to
you competing to fighting
another another human being how do you
mike has an interesting story about it
like what'd you say if i'm smoking weed
yeah do you think it would help you do
you think it would help
with anxiety like that's why i smoked it
i was
a little too paranoid the night before
so i smoked the night before
to get some rest and cool out yeah you
know i believe that helps me
i was relaxing to fight the fight i
broke the guy's eye socket his cheek
bone and his back his rib hoodie because
he turned around while i was throwing
punches
and um i was calm relaxed
yeah you know and it was um i know it
was really soothing yeah
i mean that's the same story i get from
from our fighters absolutely but i
i just and it's interesting because i've
had you know i've had talks with
the nevada state athletic commission bob
bennett who's their executive director
he's
just like me former federal agent and
you know i think
they've had some preliminary discussions
about hey why don't we just get rid of
marijuana to be tested all together
i mean yeah it's legal in nevada so
there's no you notice this is when it's
really bad listen this is when it gets
bad listen um when it comes to drugs
because
when it comes to drug tests you know we
could all beat the cocaine
we could all be cocaine drug testing you
have to stay away from it for three days
or so we could beat that right
but but we got 45 days yeah we gotta
wait 45 days in our system
and i think it stays in our system
because it belongs the weed comes out i
mean
cocaine comes out cause it doesn't
belong there our body's trying to get
rid of it
um you know yeah that's interesting
interesting theory dude yeah that's real
so we're trying to get rid of
to do different things in our bodies
anyway endogenous cannabinoids
that help us with our appetite and our
sleep rhythms and
our mood this makes us hungry this we do
some cocaine [ __ ] we shut
down boom all of our systems shut down
we don't hear nothing we don't see
nothing it's all
losing the illusions and [ __ ] we don't
hear [ __ ] see [ __ ]
and we're on some [ __ ] energy we
don't even know about them yeah
i care about nobody i don't care about
nobody
in terms of things that aren't supposed
to be in your body i think this is real
hypocritical in the world of anti-doping
is
xanax ambien some of the opioids
talked about this earlier are allowed
but you can't use
a little marijuana the night for a fight
to sleep i mean that's just that's
flat out wrong yeah i think absolutely
i mean do you why do what's the concept
why do we think that way
why find out why is it the greatest
thinkers in that particular field why do
they think that
for these available pharma companies the
influence that big pharma has over
lawmakers
um they see marijuana as you know
potential roadblock to their earnings
potential
um right i think yeah i've done almost
every drug i can
think of you know instead of probably i
don't
think i do i smoke crack before you
didn't affect me i did smoke mess before
you just didn't [ __ ]
just it wasn't my thing it didn't affect
me right i didn't like it it wasn't my
stuff right
i did the i did the toad right
and changed my whole perspective on life
and drugs and all that [ __ ]
you know just changed everything i ever
thought about drugs it made me say drug
laying [ __ ] if it's not like this
if you can't make me feel like this then
i can't use you anymore
so what do you do with a drug like that
what do you do with a drug like so why
is the toe like
illegal that's the closest thing to make
you
have an engagement with god do you know
from my perspective
do you know about 5meo dmt or dmt
or yeah and i'm not sure i think i guess
dmt is a scheduled one
it is a schedule one but speaking of
schedule one how the hell
is marijuana yes in the same category as
crack cocaine cocaine methamphetamine
are you kidding me that didn't even work
out look i'm not i'm not sitting here a
proponent of everybody go out and use
marijuana or drugs
but when looking at people with medical
conditions
physical conditions psychological
conditions and given a choice between
a purely synthetic drug that's you know
processed by the liver through the
kidneys versus
a natural plant where there's no
evidence of that that type of toxicity
i just don't get it it's so you know
it's so mexican right what's that it's
nixon nixon yeah created the dea in 1973
and look i i was in the front lines of
the war
on drugs in america it's not working
yeah we're 45 years into it this is what
it is um
is no it's no end to it it's no end to
drugs and cocaine and acid and all that
[ __ ] and method there's no end to that
that's never gonna end
it's gonna be here when our
great-great-great-great grandkids die
it's never going anywhere yeah i created
it we make it
the toad is natural all this [ __ ] and
after we make it yeah
yeah yeah and there's there's good
intelligent people that i work with that
are working it so it's not for lack of
effort but
just the demand is too high and
you took a quarter of that money and put
it into education
rehab for those that needed it and
developed the problem
and i think you have a much better
society than than what you do now i talk
about
prison overpopulation with non-violent
drug offenders i mean marijuana being a
schedule one drug there's
instances where if you sell enough of it
you could be facing a
mandatory minimum sentence of 10 years
yeah
yeah it's ridiculous i think society is
realizing that
that's ridiculous and that's why we
haven't um we're getting easier on the
marijuana laws
i think we're getting there i agree with
you yeah i believe it's just an
overwhelming
it's almost overwhelming call for a
change and i think it's just gonna be
it's a no-brainer to have to give in
it's almost like when the christians
became legalized religion
it was so much they just couldn't stop
it um chris
chris what's his name constantine all
that he had to turn christian
he's just it was overcoming him it was
crushing him and his children and his
children's children they couldn't stop
it so we had to make that
um a religion of the country that was in
rome
no constantino noble what is it what is
what is that um
turkey turkey yeah yeah
mike's a history guy too man awesome
yeah and when you think about
marijuana in a form it's like religion
it's a form of religion yeah marijuana
absolutely you know there are people who
are
who actually have a religion about it
what are their names
and that the rastafarians are they well
the rastafarians i think cannabis is a
big part of their
culture but it's not like a centerpiece
these people actually it's like a
centerpiece of their
culture i told you about that tribe in
africa the dogon tribe who have a
yearly cannabis celebration and they
believe that this
ancient alien race from the serious
stars came down and brought cannabis to
it sirius are the dog stars there's two
of them a and b
cannabis means two dogs so they have
all these cave paintings about people
from the heavens coming down to the
earth and giving them this plant because
it will bring them peace
and so i mean there are people that are
[ __ ] into it
yeah well it is that
though you know i think that there's an
intelligence to all this plant
life you know and somehow in our western
culture we've convinced ourselves that
we know better
and that we can create something better
in a lab that's safer
or at least that's become profitable so
that's the direction it's gone you know
i mean i always try to look at it it's
just because my world from a sport
perspective and the reality is
you know mma the ufc is probably one of
the most physically
grueling yeah damaging to your body over
you know short and long term sports out
there and
you know again i'm not a proponent of
everybody going out and using things but
when you have certain conditions you're
in pain
all the time and you look at the
alternatives that are out there
synthetic man-made toxic to the liver
kidney
versus a plant yeah that you know i
think it's
unquestioned that you know probably it
doesn't have a lot of the addictive
properties that
an opioid would certainly um and that
there's no evidence that i've ever found
of toxicity
yeah um man it sure seems to me like are
there more reasonable people like you
jeff and the fda
and the dea they have to do but their
hands are tied
yes i struggle with that a lot i mean
you're tasked to enforce the laws of
this country many of which you may not
agree with
and you know that's it was tough
definitely
i guess you have to be the kind of
person to take that job
right true i mean there's like in every
walk of life there's all kinds of
law enforcement agents officers the
majority in my opinion with working them
are really good people
or some that yeah that aren't in it for
the right reasons maybe
yep yeah maybe they're just finding
themselves i
i thought something to believe you know
since my conscience
was hard for me to believe in really bad
people now
i know that's even [ __ ] up they think
but it's hard for me to think of people
bad if they're misguided
they have wrong perceptions of what they
think life is and what their happiness
is
well i would just challenge you on that
with you know there's dark and light in
the world
oh no doubt about it no so maybe there
are people who
are gravitated towards
darkness and evil and i don't know maybe
that's just
part of the balance of the universe
nobody ever showed them the essence of
the light
yeah once you find the essence of device
you can't run back yeah
it's true jeff
it's got to be going down in the
government man we got to have some light
in there
oh well it's been awesome having you on
man big time
yeah yeah it's been great being here
mike i mean i have so much respect for
you just you know growing up in high
school in the mid
late 80s and in college your fights were
events they were neighborhood
get-togethers really
celebrations
yeah well that's how you had to be man i
tell you another quick story what you
did for me so
you know your kids are always the last
one to think you have
any type of cool factor right and they
keep you humbled
and mine certainly are like that my
middle one kira who you met a couple
weeks ago in vegas so we were driving
into the office that day
and dana's assistant calls me on the
phone so i put on the speaker in the car
and she says
her name's dre she goes hey jeff you're
in the office i said no i'm five minutes
out
said oh mike tyson and some business
partners are meeting with dana and they
want you to come in
i'm like i'll be there in five minutes i
look over at my daughter and her mouth
is like on the floor and she doesn't get
excited about anything she's like
mike tyson that's awesome i'm like yeah
i go come with me in the i go dana's a
real family guy you won't mind just come
in and so she came in there and got to
meet you and
for a second at least i was cool in the
eyes of one of my kids that doesn't
happen very regularly
so thanks beautiful thank you that's so
awesome
have you ever been in contact with the
nfl drug
policy peeps yeah yeah so you know back
in
in the balco days there was some nfl
players um there so yeah i know
uh dolph or birch um is the guy that
kind of runs their program
and good guy yeah um but you know they
have their own way of doing things and
their own agenda and
you know we'll go to conferences and
things like that together but i don't
know how much
influence or i know i don't have any
influence over
over nfl do you guys share data
on how many percentages of athletes
getting busted
and yeah so i think a real important
thing of any anti-doping program is
transparency
and i think we have the most transparent
program out there so unlike
mlb or the nfl it's like hey this guy
got suspended for four games and not
saying
why right we release all of our data so
total number of tests total number of
positives
what the athlete tested positive for i
think that's important because
trust trust is a big if you don't have
the trust of your athletes in a program
then i don't care how strong your
program is it falls apart
because they may think in the nfl you
get a player saying
if tom brady tests positive is he really
going to be treated the same as
you know the 45th man on the roster
who's a special teams player
and there's no way of the nfl approving
that because you can't see any of these
numbers or what's going on in their
program so everything we do is
absolutely wide out in the open that's
great man yeah there's no trust between
the league and the players
in the nfl that's uh that's that's
us versus the players i've talked to
have told me the same thing why can't
it can never be trusted there's always
someone that's not that's being
deceitful on one either one side is a
player
or either um the the corporate
somebody's always being deceitful yeah
oh man who's that brother i don't know
sorry i can't call well jeff great
having you man
yeah great being here but before i
forget mark rattner said to say hello to
you
and that's my man now listen mark ratner
he ran um
um the vegas athletic commission for a
hundred thousand years
right and he's just always been my
friend he's just um
he's just very special you know he's
very special you know he won't know he's
in the room he's nothing flamboyant
he's just he's just a good man but he
did tell me a story he find you a little
bit of money
over something right he was always he's
like i didn't know how mike was going to
react the next time i saw him after that
i loved those guys
man what did he have to find you because
i think i bit this [ __ ]
oh i'm so sorry but listen um people
thought i took it personal with them i
didn't take the president they took it
so
[ __ ] long why don't you just um
penalize me and let me go home and it
took
months and weeks to get this [ __ ] done i
know oh god take the money let me go
government bureaucracy right yeah
killing me in the
witnesses killing me it's killing me oh
god it's crazy man from being an athlete
know what's the biggest um
cause for these enhancement drugs and
stuff our pain we're in a lot of pain
and we're lonely a lot
yeah a lot of athletes are real lonely
yeah
absolutely lonely well that's what we
talked about when we talked about
you know addiction too man just because
you're in pain
you feel isolated you know has nothing
really to do with the drugs that you're
taking
these addictive substances become
addictive because of our own
psychology around what the whole we have
to feel
yeah in ourselves and we don't even know
we have a
whole yeah we brought to the attention
that we have a whole where what we have
a what
i don't have a whole [ __ ]
[ __ ] who you talking about
just let everybody know think sometime
who are you
be in touch with who you are because
trust me if you don't
at this stage get in touch with who you
are and get to know this person who this
is
i think it's a wasted life who are you
where have you come from why are you
here what is your purpose
really who i am i'm just somebody my
mother and father they
my father's mother was just horny one
night and boom and i came up it wasn't
that they love each other it wasn't love
they wanted the [ __ ] i came out and
um what the hell happened
what was that purpose for oh really what
was the purpose yeah
you came in you came through that portal
i had no idea
it's that look at that number that's
from another dimension dude
eight zeros more than one oh really
are we going to a prison i hope so we
can talk some people and help some
people
that'd be cool well you heard it from
mike y'all
who are you ask yourself go deep
question things
here what's my purpose i always wondered
this who's the first me who's the first
man in my family
who was the first man where was he yet
what year was he born
before christ after yes who was the
first me who's my first nose come from
where did i come from the first person
that was me my my lineage my bloodline
the first one how many how long was he
probably goes back pretty far 200
million years how long ago was he
have you traced back how far have you
been able to trace back family
that far enough yeah yeah i would love
that too
that's that fascination and then the
20th it's still in the 20th century i
think
19th century something like that it's
not even going over 300 years 200 years
i've gotten back to 1620s wow
yeah my first ancestor that came to
america her name was mary bliss parsons
she came from england and she came here
in about 1624
she was on trial for witchcraft three
times got off
how did you find that out uh my
grandmother actually
uh late last year started passing me all
this family lineage stuff because i
think she's like
she wants to pass it on and i'm the guy
in the family that
sort of the center the energy center of
my family so
i'm the guy who's getting this
information it's really cool you know
it's fascinating you know i've always
wanted the first male of my lineage
the first male of this lineage whoever
named he probably wasn't even a black
guy
he probably was white he could have been
an asian who was he
the first one you know what i mean that
turned me into this originally
after all those millions of years
hundreds of million years that came out
like this
might have been an alien bro you never
know who was that first person
yeah that first being only 1890s
uh 1889 we started filming documenting
can you imagine that 1890 we started
physically documenting besides before
you know after writing
it's [ __ ] interesting dude we should
we should have a whole part about it
and we still don't believe the people we
see in the 20s or the 1980s
we're always judging their movements we
don't know who they truly are because
they're on screen
imagine one time they have screens one
day they start having a screen for every
inch of your life to have your bathroom
photograph have your kitchen every
moment of your life you'll be
photographed
isn't it interesting about man's
need or uh gravitation to create
like cave paintings telling stories
before we learned
or started the capability of writing i
think like cuneiform
or something in like ancient mesopotamia
or um what was that other civilization
like in turkey well yeah atlantis
well whether it's a civilization that's
under turkey that's like 9 000 years old
that's older than africa another country
under
turkey africa is not the oldest country
in the world
there's countries under africa and under
other countries that's been here
millenniums
we can't even explain until we can't
even explain who these people were
yeah we don't even understand the
messages that they left us because we
think we're so superior to them we can't
even figure out the message that they
left us
yeah stonehenge and all that stuff
stonehenge we haven't even figured that
out
are those heads on easter island no
nobody knows anything
we don't know who we are how are we
gonna figure out something else we don't
even know who we are
jeff you have any thoughts on this i was
on the great wall of china i was
last november oh dude that was uh it was
just two years to make just
four thousand years i'm sorry two
thousand years at the moment it's
incredible
two thousand yeah i can finish it
without a doubt the most incredible
man-made thing i've
ever witnessed been a part of in my life
it was
i took that i left and got on a plane
and flew back to vegas that night i
walked into my house and said
was i just walking on the great wall of
china this morning is this or is this a
dream
it was just really moving nothing's
moved me like that
i did the thing that did five miles on
the great wall wow really
yeah i want to do that i got home called
my mom and dad and they said hey do you
remember the the story that your
grandmother and grandfather told you
about that i'm like
no what was it and they said in the
early 70s they were they were retired
and
they would go on trips they were one of
the first american tour groups to go
into russia when it opened up so they go
over to china
they go on the great wall of china who's
on the great wall with them
when they're up there ali oh i'm like
did they take a picture
and my mom's like no it's before like
everybody's walking around with cameras
like damn that is a story right there
that's an amazing story when i went to
um
when i went to egypt i saw the pyramids
i said
i'd like to say alexander the great
napoleon all these guys are when
they've been here all of the great
warriors before them and stuff that
you know this is the place you had to
conquer at the car you know the romans
they had to conquer egypt that was the
light
at the time yeah it's amazing
it's amazing i want to go there really
bad to egypt and see that
yeah roman's pretty awesome too yeah
yeah room grease
i went it was last year in a period of
two months we're in moscow russia for
our first show there so i'm in
red square and inside the walls of the
kremlin you can actually go in it
and then a couple of months later i'm in
tiananmen square
i went to see my forbidden city you see
linen is pretty cool in the states
see him in the states wow we were
reading about that going in there and
they've got people in the russian army
whose sole job is to take care of
linen's body so every what
month or so they bring them back
underneath underneath where the tomb is
and work on them put new skin on them
clean them up
i mean can you imagine that job crazy
what an order to be a part of oh
right that's crazy they take that
serious when you walk in that tomb too
like i had i had my hands in my pocket
and there's soldiers there going get
your hands out of your pocket like you
better you don't want anything i go
there too it's like this i went to lin
in my same thing so it's a big line
right
so the guards are gonna stop the line
and go
and i go in the front they put me in the
front so i could see the bodies and
stuff
then they let me out and stuff and i'm
like wow that's pretty cool
it's moving yeah just keep moving don't
stop just keep it moving
it's looking at mouth it looks like fake
skin and everything everything looks
fake on them
look like rubber
how would you feel about that about
lying in state for forever yeah just
this is interesting you said that my
wife and i we went to egypt so we went
to the
museum and we saw the mummy laying and
tomosister and all these guys
they got gold slippers on you know like
the thongs we wearing
or nate they're gold yeah so right um
we look at them and then i'm saying to
my wife i said with the eagle that they
had they probably loved people watching
them and then i was saying no they
didn't want people to be that's why they
put them in the
the temple thing because they didn't
want people to gawk over them
you know what i mean so my wife was
really freaking superstitious about
gawking over them and stuff
but um it was a trip watching them you
know i say to myself
this is interesting too you notice like
in the ten commandments you see moses
they always have a staff
yeah interesting only really the royals
waters
was the ass now why because they are
[ __ ] inbreeding [ __ ] their sisters
and their mothers and their uncles and
their fathers and everything
and they all had bad hips from it so
that's really why they had to walk and
staff
most of them couldn't use some thc
to ease those pains i'm gonna tell you
some more stuff too so you look up
look up cocaine dummy they have a dummy
they cut his head and check them out
and so they found that he had cocaine
and nicotine in the system
and they said there was no cocaine there
unless it was an alien plant ancient
plant a long time ago and
cut it out because they supposed to see
what it done to you i mean maybe cocaine
gave them the effect that they got they
have an afterlife
maybe you know where does the cocaine
and the nicotine come from
yeah it's going to egypt
oh we got the drug testing guide here
i don't think they were doing any drug
testing back in those days no way
we're trying to figure out what is it
they're just experimenting
no that's [ __ ] god we got we got deep
man love it
yeah we really go deep here well it's
interesting about
the pyramids and the sphinx and i was
listening to these guys talk about how
the geologists
and the paleontologists disagree on the
age
of the sphinx as well the geologists say
it has to be
this rock is at least thirty thousand
years old really
yeah it was five thousand yes exactly
the paleontologists say
no that's five thousand years old
geologists go no this is
thirty 000 years old this
structure wow and because of like the
depths and the excavation that they've
done
it's just kind of mind-blowing man and
this guy i've told you about him before
mike this guy
thoth the egyptian god of wisdom who is
said to have
come to egypt to build the pyramids
from atlantis he was an atlantean priest
who traveled to egypt when atlantis was
taken over by
a flood and this is in this book the
emerald tablets that he wrote
and the pyramids are above what is
called the halls of amenti where he
where you go to be reincarnated
into the world so it's all i don't know
man
i mean we don't even know why the
pyramids are there
yeah there's people buried in them but i
mean they had pharaohs buried
300 miles outside the city that they
would take
you know and hide them because they
didn't want people looting their
tombs you know because like you said
mike everything was gold
they had these beautiful ornate statues
and things
because they need they believe that
these their
souls needed them to travel into the
next life
it's crazy they're still finding yeah
maybe please continue no you go
sorry mike i was just saying maybe we
yes we are who we think we
are yeah when we like we like we went we
took all that gold and stuff
maybe and then my my goal is following
me i'm going with my goal
well maybe we're not they're no longer
in the physical world then
you know they left the physical world
behind it with this um
spiritual world
[Music]
it's crazy all these things that we're
still finding all these clues that are
on this
planet to lead us you know to figure out
where we came from who we are i saw
something this week the
earliest footprint ever found somebody
found this
footprint of a man and determined how
does it determine if it's a man a
woman's footprint
just with the shape or size of the foot
exactly so i mean it's got me like
walking around now looking on the floor
like i want to find
a footprint that's older than that
that's crazy
um i know i'm just talking about um from
reasonable terms i just know the vikings
were here too
yeah for christopher columbus and all
those guys because when you think about
it the vikings came here with their
swords and their
mallets and all that warrior stuff but
the indians had
you know there was too many indians at
the time they had their bone arrows and
stuff
but then they came back a thousand years
later boom
what was 500 probably a thousand years
later chris columbus yeah now they got
guns
so it's easier to take over now it's
easier before you put the spoiler and
miles now you're not gonna do when they
got a hundred thousand indians with
bones and arrows
yeah you know so and they they also
found the vikings home they had
built a home there nomad style
where north america agreement
something like that yeah
yeah oh yeah dude i mean the ancient
civilizations
it's mind-boggling you know to think
about
we can where we come from we can't
explain the native americans where they
came from
yeah it's you know there's this world
that they came from china when the
chinese came here with their glory ships
back in the day
they're interested in bc before christ
treasure ships when they had their
treasure ships
they traveled the world to find out what
was in the world for 30 years they
traveled the world
the chinese yeah and ships look off
broke
and didn't try to take over
no they just wanted to see they just
wanted to see it isn't that
interesting i just wanted to see what
was what they had out there the
difference between that and say rome
who was looking to conquer and expand
the territory isn't that interesting
like why why is that well the reason is
is because um
rome was like that because rome was
basically um
living in the the lifestyle of alexander
the great they were in so
those they're so spartans they were so
afraid of his reputation they didn't
make a tweak they never made a word
until he died and then they came out of
nowhere so his name was so frightening
it was like godly to him
they you didn't even hear about wrong
roman never made a peep
until alexander the great died
they thought he was a god so when he
died he they thought it was up to them
to take over god's world
ah because he he was on such a conquest
oh he was just insane yeah he couldn't
be
he was just yeah and it was a warrior
culture
basically and they were frightened
because they had been conquered i'm sure
and people took over them and they
figured everyone's good this that's the
way to live we better conquer them
before they enslave us that's the only
way to think
yeah else they think they're ordained by
god and god gave them the
the ordained power to conquer the world
well that's alexander the great thought
so then why do you think the chinese
didn't have that philosophy well i think
um they didn't have that philosophy
because they had different teaching they
have different um they had they had the
[ __ ]
zen then they had um
what's the other guy the indians come on
religion
hindu hindu and all that stuff in the
other religions uh
buddhism and all that stuff yeah you
know i mean
but um there's been a time when um
when the chinese because you know they
um they formatted their country the same
time that the punic wars was going on
like the
2000 2020s and stuff
you know what i mean so they did the
same they they um
it was really wrong with um
being built being built at the same
particular time
oh interesting you guys game of thrones
watchers oh god my wife loves this stuff
yeah i haven't
i haven't watched much oh that's crazy
man look they killed all the dead people
yeah they wiped them out man and i
had dropped the knife and then caught
and gutted them spoiler alert
yeah she came to one of our fights and
uh we were in liverpool darren till was
fighting and she was sitting kind of
front row behind me but yeah she's a
she's a little badass
oh what's her name the dragon mother no
this is arya starks she's the little
oh oh yeah yeah from the stark family
many faces i watched like the first four
episodes
i was like yeah i don't know i gotta
stick with it yeah i know
maybe i will no i just started westworld
too
i watched um the tutors oh yeah
yeah i heard it king henry viii what a
interesting guy crazy right good with
women but yes they're interesting he can
get them but he normally kills them at
the end
[ __ ] up it's crazy his daughter was a
great ruler too elizabeth the first she
was a green ruler
it's nuts dude well anything else jeff
i think we've covered it all today
i have a sister yeah younger sister i
have three daughters yeah
uh oldest just graduated from college
which college
uh she went to use a banana slug you see
santa cruz ooh
over the shirt the tripod wore in uh
fiction
the slugs i love santa cruz sluggers say
that's a cool city santa cruz
yep very cannabis friendly there no
doubt they have that school
is probably one of the most liberal
schools
in america my daughter's calling like
yeah you know 420 dad like probably 95
90 percent of the schools out in the
redwood woods back there like celebrated
like yeah it's the naked run through
campus tomorrow i'm like what what
how many people are doing that's like
everybody it's for the future kids
yeah you know preparing the world for
them yeah
exactly that's awesome man well again
jeff awesome to have you here thank you
guys very much for having me really
appreciate it
yeah man bring take us home brother all
right hey everybody thank you for
listening we love you guys
remember to subscribe to our youtube
channel
hot boxing with mike tyson you can find
all our episodes there head to
hotboxingpodcast.com
for our website is that correct yes
that's correct
and uh that's about it y'all until next
time i'm evan britton and i'm mike tyson
this is jeff novitskiy we're out of here
bye and thank you jeff
that was fun
[Music]